now go three three times around still
just repeating moves here get any time
on the clock the players do have a two
second increment
but he's stuck how can he break through
here Magnus Carlsen getting F3 and it's
gone
E2 and rugby one
Judah I think he spotted a direct win
there he's still gonna find it though
Magnus Carlson he's got three pawns now
to be Pawn running
car is about to resign three pauses too
much she's relaxed
[Music]
page 390
and I mean oh my God what a game what a
turnaround I mean this just goes to show
it's all about holding the nerves when
the clock is ticking down on its final
seconds and here comes F3 oh what's that
isn't it
anything at this point
pawns are rolling
black is about to win
[Music]